venez-vous de toucher ma jambe hé [ __ ]
[Musique]
en préparant cette émission CBS News a
commandé une enquête par l'opinion
Research Corporation sur les
attitudes du public envers l'homosexualité, nous avons
découvert que les Américains considèrent l'
homosexualité plus nocive pour la société
que l'adultère, l'avortement ou la prostitution
[Musique]
[Applaudissements  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Musique
] c'est un jour particulièrement déchirant
tous nos amis nos compatriotes américains
qui sont lesbiennes gays bisexuelles ou
transgenres
le tireur a ciblé une boîte de nuit où les
gens se réunissaient pour être avec des amis
pour danser et chanter et vivre
[Musique]